Avatar the way of water is a triumphant
return to Pandora but not everything is
the same some viewers noticed that the
romance from the first movie has evolved
into a different kind of love this time
around but the feedback has mostly been
positive in the most General sense
Avatar is a story we have all seen
before man is thrown into an alien
culture man falls for the beautiful
daughter of the clan leader man
transfers his soul into a nine foot tall
alien body after realizing the culture
is not actually hostile a tale as old as
time while director James Cameron used
some well-traversed tropes for the 2009
film many elements still hit home
audiences knew what they were in for
when they saw Jake Sully meet impressive
Warrior natiri when a character hates
that they have to teach some interlope
or the ways of her people you know where
it's going
the first it was just Motors
and then everything changed okay I fell
in love when Jake and natiri do get
together it's earned Jake becomes a more
enlightened and understanding person he
learns that his military training was
prejudicial and the navi should be able
to protect their home Jake makes a great
sacrifice and leaves behind everything
he knows to be with natiri on Pandora
this could have been a romantic bookend
for a sequel but Avatar the way of water
revisits the couple more than a decade
later and the Romantic Dynamic has
definitely shifted in the time since we
last saw Jake and natiri a lot has
changed Avatar showed the passion and
longing often seen at the beginning of a
romance now we're catching up with these
lovebirds after around 14 years together
and with some additions to the family by
the time of Avatar the way of water
natiri has given birth to three children
natayam loak and tuke they have also
adopted Dr Grace Augustine's Navi
daughter Kiri and eventually they do the
same for Wayward human spider it's a
mixed family as many modern families are
some redditors noted that this leaves
little time for romance but others
chimed in to say that it reflects how
life really is one commented I think
it's likely that those people who liked
the romance element from the first film
have now 13 years later took the romance
in their own life and had a kid and a
family which is heavily present in this
film making it still incredibly
relatable to them the film grew up just
like the people outside waiting for it
another wrote for me it was more
emotional than the first one and I think
Avatar goes beyond the romance clearly
the story a family love serves as a
satisfying replacement for the romance
for many viewers however others have
called out what they see as a different
glaring oversight in the film I need you
with me
and I need you to be strong natiri was
originally an extremely complex
character the latest of James Cameron's
impressive heroines an accomplished
Warrior of her clan she feels a profound
sense of Duty and doesn't shy away when
the occasion calls for it in the first
movie she demands that Jake take
responsibility for his duplicity when
she discovers he had been lying to her
about his motivations this Rich
character Arc was sorely missing in the
sequel and fans took note one redditor
wrote I will say that I am quite sad we
didn't get more of Jake and natiri plus
she was sidelined like 80 to 90 percent
of the film I hope we get more of them
in the next film another user chimed in
saying nitiri left her whole family
behind and then we don't know if she
made new family in the archipelago I
guess wait for Avatar 3 critics also
found her story to be lacking CBR
pointed out that the main thrust of way
of water focuses on the children and
less so the parents the independent was
even harsher concluding that natiri's
storyline was the least satisfying
[Music]